hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out the red band trailer for a
vacation I think it's just a
continuation actually I never really
read up on it not gonna lie but I think
Chevy Chase is in this so he's in it it
must just be a Content whatever it's a
trailer and it's been forever since this
franchise continued so they should make
it in a way where if audience haven't
heard of this franchise yet that they
will still catch on marketing while the
world
look who made it hi dad morning rusty
these families go abroad I gotta shake
things up we're driving to Walley world
what
this is [ __ ] right here I took the
Walley world when I was a kid was the
best time I ever had so you want to redo
your vacation from 30 years ago this
will be completely different I've never
even heard of the original vacation
doesn't matter the new vacation will
stand on its own I'm here to answer any
questions you might have
what's a rim job I would guess a rim job
is when you kiss someone with your mouth
closed okay so you're only using the rim
of your mouth you're not too old to let
your dad give you a goodnight rim job
mr. six and cool what we needed was a
whole list I rest off sounds like you
found yourself a glory hole hot springs
up ahead this is beautiful I say we call
it R is walled Springer's minerals that
are in this mud draw toxins out of the
body just me
oh I don't think this is a hot spring
crazy just want to make sure y'all had
everything you need for the night
do you remote okay let me show you on
off pretty straightforward he totally
just came in here to show off his
six-pack but some tunes
Wow
it is been a while since I've seen a
trailer for a comedy where I'm like that
looks like a really good time honestly I
don't really remember the vacation
movies last when I remember watching was
Christmas vacation I remember really
enjoying it but I honestly couldn't even
tell you how it ends I totally forgot I
just love the self-awareness of that one
line saying I've never even heard of the
original vacation anytime like twice
what sold me on 21 Jump Street when I
saw that self-awareness humour the in
the trailers and seeing that for some
reason it just makes me go wow give
these guys a chance you know those look
like an updated version of what the
vacation movies were like and I gotta
say like Ed Helms the only movie I see
man that was like big was The Hangover
where he was he's funny in it I liked
him in the office as well but this looks
like he's gonna do a great job you see
in the office how he's got good timing
with his dialogue that he knows how to
make lines really funny and then you see
in the hangover that he can also do some
like physical comedy and he's perfect
for this kind of film and christina
applegate
is still so [ __ ] hot I remember her
I'm married with children but mm-hmm to
her all the time but the main reason I
got to see this
is for Chris Hemsworth's role that I
loved seeing a serious actor go full-out
comedy and it works best when it's in a
cameo not when it's like really the
whole entire film sometimes that works
out great Channing Tatum in 21 Jump
Street he's not the most seriously
taking actor at that time but when he
broke out with 21 Jump Street he created
a whole new level of respect James
Franco did that with pineapple Express
but I like it when it's just a cameo and
it seems like this is gonna be a small
role I love how he's just making fun of
his image that he has and just sort of
embracing it it's really [ __ ] funny
rating time I will definitely be going
to the theaters to see the vacation
alright guys thanks tell me that was
that if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where we're trying to get a
product placement by getting a certain
amount of followers I like them I don't
prepare props ever mini jambox --is I
can totally get on board with you guys
you know sponsoring me that would be
awesome
many jam boxes are great for many things
you can totally like play music really
loud you can hook it up to your laptop
and watch YouTube videos you can hook it
up to your phone and before you go to
bed cuz you know when you like try to
watch porn on your laptop it kind of can
hurt your neck a little bit depending
how your cough but with this you could
just watch it on your phone and you can
put it right against your ear so you can
listen to the [ __ ] the whole time
Zayn Khan hey man I got an Instagram
account called insane reviews that's
almost as clever as the real rejects is
it cool if I could have a shout-out sure
Zayn Khan will give you a shout out yeah
yeah you're like 12 years old or
something man it's cool to have you as a
subscriber
I hope these sexual talks that I give on
this channel are very educational for
you you know in America talking about
sex it's kind of frowned upon you know
it's like something we shouldn't speak
about so I choose to speak about it
because if we have freedoms each so my
friend Zane Khan I want you to know that
if you need any sexual education just
tune into every episode of the real
rejects